martes 11 de septiembre de 2001
es un día soleado en nueva york' la
ciudad se prepara para las elecciones
primarias del partido republicano y del
demócrata para la alcaldía
[Música]
a las 8 46 de la mañana los informativos
del mundo comienzan a reportar sobre un
accidente en la torre norte del world
trade center la confusión es total los
reportes indican que un pequeño avión
volando bajo un helicóptero se chocó con
el edificio
17 minutos después a las 9 de la mañana
con tres minutos y con todas las cámaras
enfocadas en nueva york' el mundo mira
atónito como un boeing 757 un vuelo
comercial de united airlines se estrella
contra la torre sur
[Música]
ahora no había dudas el país más
poderoso del mundo estaba bajo ataque
907 sarasota florida el presidente
george bush se encuentra reunido con
unos niños de una escuela primaria
cuando el jefe de personal le avisa que
embistieron la segunda torre
simultáneamente la administración
federal de aviación ordena la
prohibición de despegue de todos los
aviones que se dirigen o sobrevuelan el
espacio aéreo de nueva york'
werner schulz ready lane
est
efe
el sol se desahogaron
en el bosque dirección
los leones
entre los fox
sí
en el firmamento
m
[Aplausos]
[Música]
arlington virginia 937
se reporta una explosión en el corazón
de la defensa estadounidense otro avión
se estrella contra el pentágono
en word
bueno iba a trabajar de repente escuchó
un gran ruido y simplemente salir de
inmediato del auto luego vimos que el
avión se acercaba y rodeaba está área y
el ala subía y bajaba de esta manera
luego fue solo unos segundos y se
estrelló de inmediato
a las 9 45 o se prohíbe el despegue de
cualquier aeronave en eeuu y se ordena
del aterrizaje inmediato de todos los
vuelos nacionales por primera vez en la
historia del país el congreso y el ala
oeste de la casa blanca' son evacuados
tras los primeros impactos y con la
certeza de otro secuestro la fuerza
aérea comienza a buscar desesperadamente
el vuelo 93 de united airlines que
partió del aeropuerto internacional de
newark hacia san francisco
[Música]
959 la segunda torre en ser impactada es
la primera en caer uno de los iconos del
poder estadounidense es derrumbado
[Música]
10 03 shanksville pensilvania
a unos 450 km de la gran manzana el
vuelo 93 de united airlines cae en medio
del campo fracasando en su intento de
impactar la casa blanca o el capitolio
10 28
cae la torre norte una hora 41 minutos
después del impacto del avión
2030 washington dice tras varias horas
de silencio y confusión el presidente
bush habla nuevamente pero esta vez en
un discurso televisado en el que asegura
que eeuu no hará distinciones entre los
que cometen los actos terroristas y los
que les protegen o cobijan
después
espolí
pero posee más
en el quite angelina en él
nation
vete jefe
strong
en the great nation
de la fundación américa
en este sentido
merkel estado de ánimo en el mismo foro
en vivo del sol de estado
y
en obras en just your world
ángel bernal en la semana acá